Hi stars I'm Maddie do you want to have an intro like this one?
but you don't know how to do it and Yami
doesn't have the little person you need.
Well don't worry because this is a tutorial on how to make
the intro that has become very famous among the help spampage.
The first thing you have to do is to look for two similar photos.
then you go to CapCut and do what I do
You can put it in slow motion if you want to
You now arrange the images to the rhythm of the music.
today only
put the template that I will leave you at the
end of the video and remove the green background.
and ready Here are the templates Credits to me and Yumi please.